bonjour à tous c'est paléo news
l'émission qui fait des news avec du
vieux au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui l'extinction de l'homme de
florès l'entrepôt scène bientôt reconnu
le mystère de l'homme de piles donne
finalement résolu et des amphibiens
préhistorique
on commence par la découverte sur l'île
de flores de restes humains attribués à
l'homme moderne homo sapiens est datée
de 46 milan alors que les fossiles du
hobbit le petit homme de flores ont tout
récemment été re daté de moins cinquante
mille ans c'est à dire 30 mille ans plus
vieux comme le pensait il apparaît que
homo floresiensis a disparu peu de temps
avant l'arrivée de l'homme moderne qui
l'a remplacé voire même que son arrivée
a provoqué l'extinction de celui ci les
preuves sont encore minces mais tout
semble indiquer que l'homme de florès a
donc bien disparu plusieurs milliers
d'années plus tôt qu'on imaginait au
grand désespoir de ceux qui pensaient
qu'une population reliques avait pu
survivre jusqu'à des temps récents
toujours du côté de l'homme
voici des nouvelles de l'anthropocène
les géologues du groupe de travail sur
l'anthropocène deux anthropologues et
scène le récent sont finalement tombés
d'accord sur la réalité géologique de
cette période des temps géologiques qui
selon eux a vu l'homme devenir le
facteur dominant dans le façonnement des
paysages de la sédimentation de la
biodiversité et des climats de la
planète
néanmoins le terme et son usage ne sont
pas encore adopté par la chartre
stratigraphique pour la simple raison
que si on sait très bien où il finit on
ne sait absolument pas quand
l'anthropocène devrait commencer au delà
de l'aspect très anthropocentrique de
cette nouvelle dénomination
le grand débat scientifique qui entoure
l'entrepôt scène concerne surtout sa
définition comment serait-il dans les
années 1940 avec les premiers essais
nucléaires ou bien à la révolution
industrielle
et pourquoi ne pas placer cette limite à
l'apogée de l'empiré romain ou bien la
révolution néolithique et l'invention de
l'agriculture il ya 8000 ans après tout
c'est bien là que nos ancêtres ont
commencé à arracher les forêts en masse
pour en faire des plantations et à
tracer des routes commerciales
tout le problème de l'anthropocène et
qu'il s'agit d'une période rapide de
changement important et correspond donc
plus à une crise qu'à un étage ceux ci
continuera encore et encore de rendre
les discussions autour de sujets plutôt
houleuse
puisqu'on en parle intéressons nous
maintenant à la sixième grande crise
d'extinction
il n'est plus à démontré aujourd'hui que
la biodiversité terrestre et notamment
celle des grands mammifères aco
depuis milan une érosion qui s'est
fortement accentuée ces deux ou trois
cent dernières années
néanmoins bien que l'analogie avec la
disparition des dinosaures soit très
tentante et fûts vides tracé il restait
à démontrer que l'ampleur de
l'extinction actuelle était bien
comparable à celle qui a eu lieu il ya
66 millions d'années en effet l'ampleur
d'une extinction ne se quantifie pas à
l'aide de la diversité des mammifères ou
des grands sauriens mais en se basant
sur la diversité des invertébrés marins
or jusqu'à aujourd'hui ces données sur
les invertébrés marins manqué pour cette
sixième grande crise biologique
cela n'est désormais plus le cas et les
chiffres montrent clairement que les
vertébrés et les invertébrés marins sont
touchés par cette crise
l'estimation la plus pessimiste faite
par des chercheurs suggèrent même que
l'ampleur de cette extinction pourrait
bien dans un futur proche devenir
équivalente à celle ayant vu s'éteindre
les dinosaures il ya 65 millions
d'années les chercheurs ont aussi noté
que comparé aux effets des précédentes
extinctions dans les océans
cette nouvelle crise biologique apparaît
toucher plus sévèrement les espèces de
grande et moyenne taille à phénomène
pointant clairement la surpêche et le
facteur humain comme cause majeure de
cette extinction
cette étude illustre bien comment une
bonne connaissance du registre fossile
permet de mieux comprendre les
phénomènes actuels et comment dans ce
cas particulier elle pourrait nous
permettre une meilleure gestion de nos
stocks de produits de la mer
laisse ton au temps des dinosaures pour
parler de cette nouvelle étude qui a
montré que les dinosaures carnivores
possédant des ornementations crânienne
comme les cornes du carneau tort la
bosse nasale du t-rex où les crêtes du
dinosaure étaient aussi ceux qui avaient
le plus tendance à atteindre des grandes
tailles 2 tel corps ns et ornements
devait servir à la parade sexuelle ainsi
qu'au combat entre mâles pour la
conquête de territoires et de
partenaires sexuels comme il l'a été
encore tout récemment rappelé par une
étude réalisée par moi même et mes
collègues d'afrique du sud et de
grenoble sur l'été rapide cette fois
pour en revenir aux dinosaures ce lien
entre taille et présence d'ornementation
suggère que le gigantisme des théropodes
peut en partie s'expliquer par la
sélection sexuelle un biais de
reproduction favorisant les individus
les plus grands qui seront les seuls à
s'accoupler
cela suggère aussi que le plumage a
remplacé la taille et les ornements
crânien chez les plus petites espèces et
renforce donc l'idée que les plumes ont
évolué chez les dinosaures à des fins de
séduction et pas seulement pour la
régulation de la température du corps ou
pour le bol on termine avec un dinosaure
encore et pas n'importe lequel puisqu'il
s'agirait de
premier run it is qui est un carnivore
connu jusqu'à aujourd'hui les formes
carnivores dinosaur était limitée aux
seuls théropodes et les antilles ce cas
était connu pour ne comportait que des
espèces herbivores
yao ming aux russes appartient à la
famille des ans qu'ils osent or les
dinosaures blindés et comme son nom
l'indiqué il fut trouvée dans le
gisement chinois à la préservation
exceptionnelles du liaoning
ceci a permis la conservation du contenu
de son estomac rempli de poissons et
suggère que même parmi les dinosaures
ornithischiens certaines formes ont pu
évoluer vers un régime alimentaire plus
riche en protéines animales la curiosité
de l'émission c'est cette affirmation
pour le moins intrigante d'un article de
saïan ce poste qui titre les réfugiés
climatiques existent depuis cent mille
ans il se base sur les résultats d'une
modélisation informatique qui vient
d'être publiée dans la revue nature et
qui montre que la détérioration du
climat au nord de l'afrique ainsi que
l'ouverture ponctuelle de couloirs
migratoires ou lors des périodes les
plus humides ont favorisé de nombreuses
vague d'exode d'homo sapiens hors de son
continent natal depuis son apparition
durant ces derniers cent vingt mille ans
ce modèle démontre donc l'importance du
climat sur la dispersion de l'homme
moderne en asie puis dans le monde
il est toutefois à noter que cette
modélisation ne se base que sur le
climat et ne prend pas en compte le
registre fossile
elle présente donc de nombreuses et
importantes en cohérence avec ce que
nous racontent les restes
paléontologique et archéologiques
notamment elle fait entrer l'homme
moderne en europe et sur l'île de flores
près de 30 à 40 mille ans plus tôt que
ne le documente leurs plus anciens
fossiles
il ne faut donc pas perdre de vue que ce
modèle montre avant tout quelle aurait
été la répartition théorique d'homo
sapiens
si le climat avait été le seul facteur
influençant sa répartition et si il
avait aidé la seule espèce d'hominidé
sur terre en effet le retard de
l'arrivée de l'homme moderne sur l'île
de flores et en europe illustre
parfaitement comment l'existence du
hobbit et de l'homme de néandertal
respectivement 11 significativement
ralenti la conquête d'homo sapiens par
rapport à ce que prévoit ce modèle
théorique purement climatique pour la
rubrique vintage nous revenons en 1912
quand le paléontologue britannique
arthur smits woodward annonce à la
découverte d'un nouvel hominidé par un
amateur d'antiquités nommé charles
dawson dans la petite ville d'angleterre
de piles da
cet hominidé connu sous le nom de
l'homme de piltdown est célèbre pour
être l'une des plus grandes supercheries
scientifique du 20e siècle
un crâne humain médiévale habilement
associé à une mâchoire d'orangs outans
moderne
dès l'annoncé de sa découverte
l'authenticité du fossile fut critiquée
beaucoup y voyant une mâchoire de singes
qu'on aurait assemblée à un crâne humain
sans rapport avec elle certains iront
même jusqu'à suspecter que
l'articulation de la mâchoire a été
volontairement brisé afin qu'on ne
puisse pas voir qu'elle ne correspondait
pas à celle du crâne
dès 1914 des études par rayons x seront
entreprises pour vérifier l'authenticité
de certains spécimens fossiles de
piltdown il faut dire que l'homme de
piltdown arrivé comme un cheveu sur la
soupe puisque avant lui le français du
bois avait déjà découvert l'homme de jab
à homo erectus tandis qu'en europe on
connaissait depuis longtemps l'homme de
néandertal et qu'on venait de découvrir
homo heidelbergensis un prêt
néandertaliens tous ces restes indiqué
que la mâchoire des hominidés s'était
d'abord réduit depuis que le cerveau
s'était mis à grossir exponentiellement
après coup or l'homme de piltdown avec
sa mâchoire robuste et simiesque et son
volume crânien très gros indiquaient
tout le contraire
dès lors bien qu'il ne fût pas oublié
dans les manuels il fut néanmoins
relégué au rang de simple anomalie par
les spécialistes français et américains
de l'époque qui jugeait que l'homme de
piltdown appartenait à une ligne et hâte
et sans descendance d'hominidés il n'y
avait que les britanniques pour défendre
l'appartenance de l'homme de piltdown
dans la lignée ancestrale de l'homme
moderne
cet isolement de l'homme de piltdown a
été d'autant plus renforcé par la
découverte d'australopithecus en afrique
du sud
en 1925 cet hominidé bien plus anciens
avaient en effet un cerveau bien plus
petit que tous les autres
la supercherie ne peut être
définitivement démontré qu'en 1953
bien après la mort de woodward et dawson
quand l'accès au matériel original et
non à des moulages ainsi que la
modernisation des techniques de datation
a permis aux sceptiques d'analysé
directement les fossiles de piltdown ces
analyses permière de déterminer que le
crâne n'était pas un fossile mais à
crâne d'homme moderne datant du
moyen-âge et que la mâchoire appartenait
à un orang outan dont les dents avait
été mené pour ressembler à celle d'un
vieil homme
aujourd'hui s'il le faut a été révélée
il n'en demeure pas moins un mystère de
taille qui est le coupable de cette
supercherie et pourquoi at il fait ça
peut-être même était-il plusieurs en
effet près de vingt suspects et
complices potentiels ont été pointés du
doigt depuis 1953
encore aujourd'hui ces questions font
couler beaucoup d'encre et un article
publié cette année a tenté grâce à un
nouvel examen aux rayons x et à des
analyses adn et g
chimiques de caractériser le mode
opératoire du des coupables afin de les
démasquer ces analyses ont montré que
les os et les dents ont été remplis de
gravier usées brisées est un thé afin de
leur donner l'apparence d'authentiqués
fossiles de la pâte a été utilisé pour
recoller grossièrement le tout soit au
moins trois fragments de crâne humain
différent et une mâchoire d'orangs
outans comme le confirment les analyses
adn
les paléoanthropologues ont ainsi
découvert que le mode opératoire de
fabrication des faux cils était le même
pour les cils de piles dames 1 le site
de découverte originel et pour piles
dans 2 un autre site dont seul le
paléontologue amateur charles dawson
connaissait l'emplacement et où il avait
été le seul à fouiller par ailleurs 38
autres fossiles furent découverts dans
sa collection personnelle tous falsifiés
à peu près de la même façon enfin plus
rien n'a jamais été retrouvé à pilsen
après la mort de dawson en 1916 malgré
de nombreuses campagnes de fouilles
cette nouvelle étude désigne donc dawson
comme seul et unique faussaires
néanmoins le professeur francis
thackeray paléoanthropologue en afrique
du sud a répondu à cet article en
rappelant que la mâchoire d'orangs
outans ainsi que la faune associée à
l'homme de piltdown sur le gisement et
qui comportait entre autre des restes
d'éléphants venant selon toute
vraisemblance de l'île de malte n'ont pu
être fournies que par un ou plusieurs
complices certainement des académiciens
ayant accès à des collections muséales
le conservateur du british muséum de
l'époque fut parmi les plus sérieusement
accusé de complicité par le passé mais
thackeray avancent qu'il pourrait en
fait s'agir du célèbre
paléoanthropologue et prêtre jésuite
pierre teilhard de chardin
ce dernier était en effet associé aux
fouilles de piles d'un an à l'époque et
avait même découvert l'une des canines
du célèbre canular à l'appui de cette
hypothèse de nombreuses déclarations
faites par deux chardin dans ses
correspondances et notamment une date et
de l'année de la découverte de piles
d'armes en 1913 où il déclarait il fut
un temps où la préhistoire méritait
d'être suspecté ou plaisanté la sphère
de l'homme de piltdown est aujourd'hui
abondamment instrumentalisé par les anti
évolutionniste afin de décrédibiliser la
paléoanthropologie mais dans cette
histoire les paléoanthropologues ne se
sont pour la plupart pas fait avoir et
arthur smith woodward plutôt qu'un
coupable a été en fait le dindon de la
farce
heureusement pour sa réputation la
supercherie ne fut révélé que neuf ans
après sa mort si les motivations de 2,5
pour fabriquer un faux apparaissent
aujourd'hui évidente l'homme était en
effet connu pour ses nombreuses
tentatives d'accéder à une eau
connaissances scientifiques officiels
malgré sa condition d'amateurs les
motifs qui auraient poussé teilhard de
chardin à s'associer avec lui reste
floue de chardin est connu pour être un
grand défenseur d'idées qu'on associe
aujourd'hui au dessein intelligent et
peut-être son but est est il de se
moquer de discréditer les
paléoanthropologues anglais ces derniers
étant un peu trop avides de découvrir un
ancêtre britannique
alors qu'on avait découvert des
hominidés partout ailleurs dans le monde
de ce point de vue tu as créé rejoint
stephen jay gould en pensant qu'il
s'agirait plutôt d'une mauvaise blague
qui aurait pris un peu trop d'ampleur et
mal tourné ainsi si les preuves
circonstancielles semble tout pointé
dans la direction d'un coupable il reste
encore à identifier son complice le coup
de coeur de cette émission c'est le
muséum d'histoire naturelle de londres
qui s'est associé avec google afin de
mettre en ligne les données digitales de
300 mille de ces spécimens au programme
photographies de fossiles en très haute
résolution vidéo 3d d'un brachiosaure et
d'un reptile marin géant mais aussi
visite virtuelle complète du musée grâce
à google street view
le lien est dans la description
n'hésitez pas à aller y faire un tour
l'invité du jour sébastien steyer
paléontologue au muséum d'histoire
naturelle de paris et auteur de nombreux
ouvrages que vous connaissez sûrement
tels que la terre avant les dinosaures
ou bien demain les animaux du futur
il était notre invité afin d'aborder les
progrès récents sur les connaissances à
propos des premiers tétrapodes dont il
est le spécialiste
on les écoute tout d'abord nous parlons
de son dernier article sur les
techniques de prédation chez les
amphibiens temenos font ils alors le but
c'était de c'était de tester en fait
cette vieille idée comme pointe des
technos condyle ces grands amphibiens au
la préhistoire occupé systématiquement
les niches écologiques des crocos en
fait actuel ta crème dans les papiers
dans la littérature scientifique depuis
des décennies et en fait on se base pour
dire ça sur des comparaisons très vague
et très générales sur les marches au
type mancelle de morphotype de crâne et
nous avec josette fortunées
d'universités de barcelone qui est post
doc on est que moi à paris on s'est dit
qu'on allait tester en fait cette
hypothèse là avec des analyses de
biomécanique pour mieux comprendre
comment s'est elle n'ose pondent il
attrape leur poids et en faisant donc de
la biomécanique 3d est un petit peu de
morpho mettrie géométriques on s'est
rendu compte que les technos pont-digue
enfin ce qu'on a étudié qui sont des
thèmes respondi lacets généralistes en
fait avait une préhension des proies
très particulière et donc apparemment il
occupait plutôt des niches écologiques
particulière aussi
ensuite on a comparé c'est toujours
certaines bosses pont deal avec la salle
à manger en la fameuse salle amende
géante en fait alors soit du japon soit
de chine il ya aussi quelques espèces
aux états unis on april espèces
américaine parce que le matériel est
plus disponible et on a essayé de voir
si au contraire on n'est pas dans la
niche écologique en fête de la sant
l'amant géantes actuelle alors il faut
savoir aussi que les technos pondicq
sont souvent comparés à des salamandres
géantes
parce que ils étaient des amphibiens or
c'est pas exactement le même groupe en
fait les thèmes aux seconds ils
appartiennent justement c'était beau ses
fans tandis que les amphibiens
salamandre et des grenouilles
appartiennent à un autre groupe assez
différent qu'on appelle les dix
amphibiens ou les amphibiens moderne
fait et donc on parlera du langage on
peut comparer un peu trop rapidement
en fait les amphibiens moderne des
amphibiens entre dimitri story et donc
c'était le but de l'étude c'était deux
avec les mêmes méthodes en fait de
morpho mettrie 3d de biomécanique de
tester ou se positionne en fait l'écran
doté mousse pont d'yves généralistes et
les crânes de d'analogue en fait actuel
dont crocodiliens et salamandres géantes
actuelle pour essayer de mieux cerner le
mode de vie de ces gosses et fall de
l'époque et on a des précisions en fait
sur le sur l'appréhension des points qui
étaient qui était très particulière
c'était une technique en fait mix entre
la saisie de la proie de front un peu
comme les crocodiles qui chasse à
l'affût et l'aspiration aussi d'un
entonnoir d'eau en fait d'une partie de
l'eau de l'environnement
un petit peu comme certains amphibiens
aux signes actuels ou même certains
invertébrés marins de type poisson qui
aspirent en fait carrément l'eau et les
pois et les poissons ou les autres
organismes qui sont dans l'eau donc
c'est un mélange entre la capture
vraiment de type prédation et chasse est
ce qu'on appelle le succès feeling c'est
à dire une aspiration dans une certaine
quantité d'eau pour aider en fait à la
prise et au maintien en tête de la proa
avant de la broyé et ensuite de
l'ingurgiter on a étudié deux espèces du
trias qui ont des crânes ni trop court
comme la seule amende géante nitrose
allongé comme le guardian on parle de
crâne généraliste et on a observé qu'en
fait ce système de chasse étaient
particulièrement efficace parce que les
technos pont d'iéna vives jusqu'au
milieu du crétacé à peu près ils
s'éteignent à moins 100 millions
d'années et ils apparaissent ya peu près
350 millions d'années
donc c'est 200 millions d'années de
succès évolutif serait peut-être dû à
cette stratégie de chasse en fait unique
finalement dans mon animal de l'époque
on est on espère et c'est ce qu'on est
en train de faire en fait on étend ses
méthodes à ces nouvelles de calcul et de
l'observation en tête de répartition du
stress biomécanique lors de tension en
fait
même externe recettes au crâne on est en
train d'appliquer cette méthode aux fins
multiples coolus pour essayer de mieux
comprendre pourquoi il avait une tête en
forme de boomerang
c'est une des plus connues c'est un
petit peu la star de ces amphibiens
préhistorique parce qu'il avait une
tronche un petit peu bizarre et le but
de cette étude en espoirs ce qu'on
appelle la faillite et les mannequins
malaysie ce but là et de notamment de
mieux comprendre déjà la symétrie
en un mot ça fait le boomerang en
question et plus naudin plus longue par
don d'un côté que de l'autre et on sait
pas pourquoi alors ça peut poser des
soucis au niveau de la pénétration de
l'environnement physique c'est-à-dire la
nage en fait lors de la nage est ce que
ça veut dire qu'ils nageaient en rond
sans doute pas et peut-être qu'il
oriente est en fait son crâne d'un côté
pour pour avancer droit vers sa foi donc
on est en train de modéliser de
quantifier tout ça pour mieux comprendre
aussi la croissance de ce boomerang là
parce que quand ils naissent les forme
larvaire et les semble juvénile sont pas
tout de suite en fait avec des têtes
bizarroïde en forme de boomerang
on a des crânes assez classique honda
s'est arrondi et c'est au cours en fait
de la croissance qu'on a une extension
très forte des zones latérales du crâne
on a peur on appelle ça en fait une
halle aux métriques croissance donc on
est en train de voir aussi ce qui se
passe en termes de es là au niveau de la
halle aux métriques croissance
c'est-à-dire finalement comment ce
boomerang et arrive à croître dans le
milieu aquatique et harry va perdurer
pendant quelques millions d'années
puisque il faut pas oublier que le
groupe des diplô quolibets les antilles
bien tête de boomerang à une répartition
stratigraphique c'est assez longue
puis il a accepté de commenter le
dernier article de sophie sanchez et de
ses collaborateurs de grenoble cambridge
et uppsala et en se basant sur une
analyse très fine par rayonnement
synchrotron des eaux du célèbre
tétrapodes à canto stega suggère que les
eaux étaient encore en cours de
croissance ce qui voudrait dire que tous
les spécimens d'un cantos tega connu
jusqu alors seraient en fait des
juvéniles et je suis sain le trait parce
que sophie sanchez je la connais bien
c'est une ancienne boqueteaux rente que
j'ai encadré et je suis très
et content qu'elle ait pu publier en
fait sur un canton s'était guère dans un
cadre de collaboration de coopération
toute cette belle étude a pu se faire et
c'est super et effectivement elle a mis
en évidence soit la rétention je sais
plus si elle ne discute dans son article
elle parle de caractère non adultes
enfin prêt adultes et du coup ça veut
dire deux choses ça veut dire soit en
fait tous les à canton sega comprenait
ce sont finalement des sorgues juvénile
ou en tout cas prêt à bulles qui se sont
fossilisés un taux sur le taux soit ce
sont des 100 ma bulle mais qu'ils
retiennent en 7 des caractères prêt à
lui parle plutôt dans ce cas-là donné au
tennis
en tout cas des terreaux cronie du
développement il faudrait voir dans les
détails si ce sont des protéines ou pas
mais c'est intéressant parce que quand
on se tait gars conserve devait
branchies il respirait en fait dans
l'eau il était essentiellement à trois
types voire même marin d'après certaines
études sédimentaires et taphonomie en
tout cas marginaux littoral et le sel
que des caractères juvénile a été
observée en fait à l'intérieur de la
structure osseuse rejoint un petit peu
les observations plus générale sur la
persistance de branchies chez ses formes
alors soit juvénile soit très attendu
presqu'à lui et je trouve ça très
intéressant effectivement alors l'adulte
aurait pu être terrestre comme il aurait
pu être aussi aquatiques en fait comme
le prix adulte peut-être qui va se
fossiliser un peu plus loin dans
d'autres environnements pas forcément
plus terrestre mais plus plus chaud ou
alors peut-être qu'il sait pas
fossilisées tout simplement peut-être un
billet taxonomique pour l'instant je
pense qu'on manque encore cruellement
beaux spécimens d'un quant au stévia en
termes de nombre d'individus au cde
comment dire de retenir une hypothèse
par rapport aux autres mois ça
m'étonnerait pas que l'on trouve dans
des volières moyens quelque part dans le
monde
une forme un peu bizarroïdes pour faire
dire hybride avec des membres qui
riediens à l'avant et des rayons osseux
à l'arrière alors là ça serait une
grande découverte mais je pense que il
faut s'y attendre parce que les
catégories qu'on colle ancêtres la
nature sept en tout cas biodiversité
sont pas forcément des catégories réel
enfin il nous a parlé de sa toute
dernière collaboration avec roland
lehoucq sur son prochain livre intitulé
combien de doigts à un extraterrestre
en fait c'était un recueil de toutes nos
chroniques science et science fiction
chronique publiée tous les mois dans le
magazine pour la science avec roland
l'ont illustré par le palais aux
artistes marc boulet et l'éditeur en
fait de l'un vous a proposé de justement
d'en sortir tous les trois ans un petit
rocker il donc là on a un premier
recueil qui sort et ça sera l'occasion
de rééditer aussi certaines chroniques
de les remettre à jour parce que quand
on traite par exemple de star wars bon
dans l'épisode 7
on a de quoi dire avec roland lehoucq
lui en termes de sciences physiques mois
en terme de sciences naturelles mais on
n'a pas encore publié en fait dans vos
relations tout ça est en cours et puis
on attend aussi d'autres star trek vont
être intéressants parce que on n'est pas
uniquement que star wars vient on est
aussi cet artiste c'est comme la
différence entre les darwiniens et les
lames artistes mais voilà on essaye de
toucher à tous les univers de la science
fiction et quels que soient les supports
on va aussi traitée de bande dessinée et
on a je sais pas si j'ai le droit de le
dire mais je peux dire quand même
maintenant en cours avec roland lehoucq
toujours un joli projet de d'expo à la
cité des sciences sur leurs valets riant
valérian et laureline bbd en fait de
science fiction française des années 80
à 70 80 luc besson est en train
d'adapter en albums et la cité des
sciences nous a demandé d'être
finalement commissaire scientifique de
l'expo à lorient et les sciences donc
affaire à suivre
la faute de dernière minute c'est la
description de pas un mais deux
squelettes complets d'un nouveau genre
de baleines vieux de sept millions
d'années et qui ont été découverts au
pérou nommé inka kujira ces squelettes
sont exceptionnelles à plusieurs titres
et notamment car les fossiles de baleine
de cette qualité sont extrêmement rares
et la préservation parfaite des fans on
l'était encore plus c'était paléo news
merci de l'avoir suivi un grand merci à
notre invité pour sa participation
toutes les infos et les liens vers les
actus sont dans la description
abonnez vous pour ne rien manquer dans
sia à très bientôt